así como también pérdidas de estatura.
El número de niños menores de cinco años con retraso en el crecimiento
en la mayoría de las regiones del mundo,
ha ido disminuyendo.
Y realmente odio decir esto,
pero el único lugar donde no ha disminuido es aquí,
en África.
Aquí, 59 millones de niños,
tres de cada 10 en ese grupo de edad,
luchan para alcanzar su potencial genético,
su potencial genético completo.
La proteína es uno de nuestros requisitos dietéticos más importantes,
y la evidencia muestra que la falta de aminoácidos esenciales,
los bloques de construcción de proteínas, en las dietas de los niños pequeños,
puede provocar retraso en el crecimiento.
Los aminoácidos esenciales se llaman esenciales
porque se pueden sintetizar en nuestros cuerpos.
Y hay que obtenerlos de nuestros alimentos
y las mejores fuentes son de origen animal:
leche, carne y huevos.
La mayoría de las proteínas que se consumen en el continente africano
se basan en cultivos de cereal.
Y aunque tenemos millones de pequeños agricultores criando animales,
la producción ganadera no es tan fácil como creemos.
Las grandes brechas ganaderas entre los países ricos y los pobres
se deben a la mala salud de los animales.
Enfermedades endémicas del ganado,
algunas de ellas transmisibles a los humanos,
amenazan no solo a los productores de ganado en esos países pobres,
sino a toda la salud humana en todos los países.
Esto es una red global de patógenos.
Muestra los patógenos encontrados en todo el mundo
de acuerdo con la base de datos mejorada de Enfermedades Infecciosas.
Y muestra los patógenos que comparten huéspedes.
En una palabra,
compartimos patógenos, y por lo tanto enfermedades,
con la especie que vivimos más cerca de:
nuestro ganado
Y llamamos a estas enfermedades zoonóticas.
Los informes recientes muestran
que la docena mortal de enfermedades zoonóticas mata a 2.2 millones de personas
y enfermar a 2.4 billones de personas anualmente.
Y Jimmy dice:
"La mayor carga de zoonosis"
recae en mil millones de ganaderos pobres".
Subestimamos por completo la importancia de nuestros pequeños agricultores.
Estamos comenzando a reconocer cuán importantes son
y cómo influyen en nuestra salud médica,
en nuestra bioseguridad
y más recientemente, en nuestra salud cognitiva y salud física.
Se encuentran en la primera línea de las epidemias zoonóticas.
Ellos prácticamente sustentan nuestra existencia.
Y ellos necesitan saber mucho,
pero la mayoría carece de conocimiento
sobre prevención y tratamiento de enfermedades del ganado.
Y ¿cómo aprenden?
Además de experiencias compartidas,
prueba y error,
los servicios agrícolas convencionales son botas en el suelo y radio.
Algo costoso y difícil de escalar frente al crecimiento de la población.
Suena bastante sombrío, ¿no?
Pero estamos en un punto interesante en África.
Estamos cambiando esa narrativa usando soluciones innovadoras,
manejando tecnologías escalables.
El conocimiento no tiene que ser costoso.
Mi compañía desarrolló una plataforma agrícola llamada iCow.
Enseñamos a los agricultores a mejorar prácticas ganaderas usando SMS
con teléfonos sencillos de gama baja.
Los agricultores reciben tres SMS por semana
con las mejores prácticas ganaderas,
y aquellos que las implementan, ven incrementos en la productividad
en un corto tiempo como tres meses.
Los primeros aumentos en la productividad son la mejora de la salud animal.
Usamos SMS porque es retentivo.
Los agricultores almacenan sus mensajes,
los escriben en libros,
y en efecto,
estamos entregando manuales agrícolas a los campos.
Reconocemos que todos somos parte de la red mundial de alimentos:
productores y consumidores,
usted y yo, y cada agricultor.
Nos estamos centrando ahora en tratar de unir a productores y consumidores
para asumir la responsabilidad no solo de la seguridad alimentaria,
sino de seguridad alimentaria
Este animal es un cebú africano-asiático cruzado con un Fleckvieh holandés.
Ella es más lechera que su madre cebú,
y es más robusta y resistente a las enfermedades que su padre Fleckvieh.
En Etiopía y Tanzania,
el programa African Dairy Genetic Gains usa SMS y genómica de vanguardia
y son pioneros en los primeros centros de reproducción láctea adaptados en África
y centros de registro de producción de productos lácteos.
Los agricultores contribuyen con sus datos de producción:
registros de ordeño,
registros de cría y de alimentación
a la plataforma ADGG.
Esto se sintetiza mediante algoritmos
de algunas de las mejores instituciones ganaderas del mundo
antes de que vuelva a manos de los agricultores
en SMS procesables.
Datos personalizados,
respuestas personalizadas
todo apunta a aumentar la productividad
basado en el potencial sobre el terreno.
Estamos en un lugar muy interesante en la agricultura en África.
Al final de este año,
tendremos casi mil millones de suscripciones de telefonía móvil.
Tenemos el poder en nuestras manos
para que los sistemas de producción ganadera no solo sean saludables,
productivos y rentables,
sino para que los agricultores estén bien informados.
Y más importante aún,
para que nuestros agricultores estén a salvo.
Trabajando con pequeños agricultores
es una de la mejor forma de garantizar la seguridad alimentaria.
Trabajar con los pequeños agricultores es una de la mejor manera
de garantizar a cada niño su oportunidad completa
y la capacidad de alcanzar su potencial genético completo.
Y aprovechando el poder de millones de pequeños agricultores
y sus tremendas vacas como la mía,
deberíamos ser capaces de detener el retraso del crecimiento en África.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)